so I had to break it to Nikki that I'm
probably getting a tattoo oh sh she was
not happy about it I think it's crazier
for you guys because you guys don't have
to have to yeah that's gonna be the best
part if anybody asks you if anybody asks
me what it what it says I'm gonna say it
it means I fear no one
[Music]
welcome back to this Ultra special
episode of the careful boys where today
all six of us have returned and we are
talking about hitting 2 million
subscribers
and it actually thank you guys sustained
because you know we've been this is our
third time probably hitting two million
but it is uh but I think I think we did
and then it just and it and it died yeah
sometimes I'll hit it for like a second
and it goes back to 1999 well you're
talking about like within this past
couple months and not not like over the
years over the years we never hit two
mil no never
okay I promise you I'm pretty sure you
guys are gonna hit two million because
all the fans have said they've but it's
never hit it's never hit
well we're actually sustaining must be
the organized crime pretty cool that's
cool congrats good job guys
and good job to you guys too for
supporting do you all of you thanks to
all the Indian Bots as well thank you
thank you Indian Bots thank you
you know I've been meeting a lot of like
uh the fans that have seen us over the
years and they said this is their
favorite group yeah which is really
really cool yeah yeah they're like I
like I like your guys's chemistry your
Dynamic you guys are like just [__]
around having a really really good time
and it's really enjoyable to hang out
with you guys and this is like because
you've been through so many phases that
this is their favorite one which is
awesome I hear that too outside of this
area era though which one was your
favorite yeah that's a good that's a
good that's a really good heart hitting
question
it felt like an era yeah my favorite was
the covid era when we were like super uh
for the first time in JK history we had
to be careful yes and um that's why we
had to be the careful boys semi woke yes
is that when you had two men uh episodes
yeah because everyone was uh they were
like I don't want to be canceled
on on camera for for first for for
breaking [__] lockdown rules
and I was like you're a little [__]
behind the camera you're still going out
you [__] lying sack of [__] so true
that's true there's also another era
where uh some some of the people would
like smoke weed every day and then they
they don't want to talk about weed on
camera and I'm like oh that's not real
some people they literally smoke weed
like all day long and then they want to
have a crisp clean image yeah but we
were never I think that was the I think
that that's not the mother I want to be
known for I was the CH I was that was
the biggest change for us
and I'm like that's weird because we've
never been like that we've always been
100 authentic you know at least we're
talking around it pretty well
I really love about this group is there
aren't those rules now yeah because back
then there's so many random rules that
people had like particulars right that
like what makes JK I think awesome is it
feels like a real conversation because
it is yeah right but then if after you
yell cut can you take that take that out
what did I tell you about last time I
don't want to talk about this
you're like oh what the [__] I thought
having a real conversation because I
know you smoke weed every day why you
gotta take that why you gotta like you
know it just becomes this crazy like
crafted conversation and then by the
time it makes it to people's computer
screens it feels constructed yeah and I
think the fans started to feel that too
because it was like well we're all
friends here too and we we want to be
considerate about like everyone's like
you know boundaries and [__] but the
boundaries got like so crazy to the
point where it was just changing the
content and then from everybody from
different people I was just like why
like then why do you even want to be on
on a show well and like you know
sometimes you want to say something but
then you self-edit just to make sure
that it's the other person feels good
yeah yeah yeah yeah because you don't
know if they feel uncomfortable yeah and
boy and you've had maybe beside bar
conversations or other or meetings or
whatever yeah and then and then but then
by the time that you're done with the
day you're like I don't think we said
anything and all that was interesting
yeah I do remember that yeah yeah yeah
I remember one of the funniest ones is
I'm gonna name any games but one of the
one of the cast
um got really crazy plastic surgery is
very obvious to the whole world and then
we would have plastic surgery topics and
then everyone like look around and then
that person was just like
I don't know experience
and they're like okay I guess that's one
of the rules that we're not gonna talk
about either
oh man there's a lot of those like all
kinds of rules all over the place that
made it feel like what's that [__]
movie where you're like trying to go
through all the lasers and [__] the
mission possible no like Sean is this
Sean Connery yeah
Sharkboy and Lava Girl what I like so
much about us talking about all these
different experiences and these
different cast members is it's all the
same [__] person
come on
I'm still I don't even know what the
[__] you guys are talking about dude I
don't either
although the wokeness was not just one
person
no I think I think that era the wokeness
era started to I don't want to say
divide but it felt weird like it felt
like people were more concerned about
being canceled so they were playing to
the threat the Potential Threat of
saying the wrong [__] versus us being
friends yes and I I think that was
probably the worst era of JK I didn't
feel like people had our backs we
weren't having each other's backs in the
room it was like Us Versus Them is like
look at me on camera I'm purchasing
going towards all the right things and
then but these guys aren't and it's like
oh [__]
and first of all that's a new belief
structure that he just developed yeah I
was yeah I saw 911 back in 2010. I
remember it and now I feel different
that's why I like the two mil mark
because uh when you see how much the
subs have gone up there's a lot of new
people that only know this yep it's
[__] sick yeah that's the cool part
because I think it was one of those
necessary
moments where maybe during the time of
building like people gravitated towards
certain personalities right and then
once that um whole era kind of like
ended and we regrouped I felt like we
shedded a lot of that and we were able
to like do the content that we want and
we attracted the type of people that
enjoy this content yeah the people are
so much nicer now too like good Lord
like it was really for a while there it
was like damn dude like I guess we suck
pretty bad but everybody hates us going
you know
lot of people came back dude but a lot
of people came back a lot of people came
back because I saw like I would still
till this day see like a flood of
comments out of nowhere just being like
Oh yeah yeah like I was just pissed
during that time but like yeah like this
is better than that I'll see some
apologies actually really like hey like
I actually thought about it I know it's
been like a year and I just I don't know
what happened got caught up in the drama
or whatever
we should get we should unsubscribe
apology not accepted yeah I think a year
later we should apologize yeah yeah yeah
we were tripping we got power hungry
that's good that's [__] meta as [__]
yeah it's a long game yeah for sure all
right so what's up with the tats man uh
we're doing it of course we're doing it
I mean who's not doing it okay I
remember specifically how this
conversation with Bart just on the side
off camera just being like yo we really
doing this like dude I don't know man
but I honestly feel like if Steve and
Nick do we all have to no I did not
speak between okay right here dude I
just want to see bar have two matching
ones yo I was okay I was one darker than
the other [__] so hilarious even Jill
was like are you [__] serious I was
like if everyone does what I'm doing yes
please you have to it's gonna be all
fresh and then it's like that's already
a mistake I'm like how funny is it to
get too much
No One's Gonna know I was watching that
video because that's that's where I was
I was working in China while we hit two
million yeah and I'm watching that video
and I'm like I'm smiling I'm laughing
I'm like this is crazy blah blah so when
you put BuzzFeed up and you have that
realization like damn does that mean I'm
gonna have both my legs I busted up it's
like four in the morning
because the conversations that'll arise
in public would be hilarious like dude
that must mean a lot to you to get two
times what is that and then me having to
explain that and it's gonna the second
one's gonna be objectively better
looking so it's gonna be like why don't
they exactly match no I want it to match
exactly so I had to break it to Nikki
then I'm probably getting a tattoo oh
[__] she was not happy about it there
was two I think it's crazier for you
guys because you guys don't have to have
to yeah I don't I don't know he's got a
champ stamp yeah and it's it's Asian
characters yeah
if anybody asks me what it what it says
I'm gonna say it it means I fear no one
and I'm gonna dead pan and I will never
break up and you're gonna run into a
Japanese person that's like that's wrong
it's gonna be a Japanese mom what was he
afraid of and I won't break I will be
like no it doesn't you're [__] you're
dumb you never [__] learn the
language then yeah
[Laughter]
after I told Nikki that [__] she was
actually pretty pretty receptive so is
the bit that Soldier where is the laugh
coming from right once I sold her on
that she's like okay I got it it's so
funny you got to wear the jumpsuit with
one pant leg up
I'm like I'm gonna get a jumpsuit with a
little clearer
it's just gonna be super sweaty right
there the whole time it's gonna be
honest that's gonna hit Stevie and
bubbly just cut a rectangle right there
you know what the funniest thing is
there's a seventh person that has that
exact same tattoo that none of you guys
know dude we're Boys
on leveling ours are all gonna be on the
right I think we're all gonna be best
friends
okay so is this really happening of
course we said we would yeah you're
gonna let a lot of the good people down
look dude did you talk to your lady if
the boys are gonna do it I'll do it yeah
oh my God I didn't expect that I don't
want it but I I don't want it but the
cameras are off it's a no dude exactly
no but not the rules on camera again
yeah I'm doing it now I'm bringing it
back I'm bringing back the old [__] oh
[__] and I'm not gonna talk about and
he's gonna have a temporary tattoo he
puts on every single time he shows up
remember the video where Nick turned
heel yeah dude yeah I don't know what
happened he just turned the heels and
I'm like I don't like that no we're not
talking about that Hollywood Nick era
lionheart's gonna be okay with you
having tattoos out against protocol
I'm actually one of the couple guys
that's got some tattoos in Spain they
got some tattoos wow and we were like
was it wrong Spanish are they as
intimidating as the one you're gonna get
I don't think so I kind of like the the
letters of of uh what does it say what's
the direct translation it says fear no
one I fear no one remember you didn't
translate yeah and it said fear everyone
yeah I kind of like that as a model I
think I live my life by that honestly
that's me honestly I feel like it
matches Nick the most in general yeah
you gotta be scared of everybody bro you
never know what people are okay if you
have like a straight up fluent Japanese
opponent one day and he sees it when
he's grappling he's like what the [__]
wouldn't that scare you a little bit
more because it's the opposite yes my
mom was like that's not even is that
even like saying fear everyone because
the it's all grammatically incorrect
yeah it's not even like a real sentence
no so what does it really
say it again hold on that'd be [__]
hilarious dude it depends it gets
different every time you do it though
when I told Tiff let's see what today's
feelings are Tiff was like you're gonna
get a tattoo with the boys and not with
me and I was like yeah yeah would you
ever do she's talking she don't wanna
get no tattoo bro ask her do you have
two million subscribers literally it
says fear nobody oh wow it's correct
today today it says fear oh but you know
why though because that's the reason why
it ended up saying fear nobody is
because you use Google Translate
so Google translate still does it wrong
I need to update Google yeah no guys it
says fear nobody and we're getting it I
like it bro I like I like the message I
think it's a great movie yeah I think
it's cool I like that it's like a mood
ring
who do I fear today sometimes I was
scared of nobody sometimes I'm being a
little all right well Nick's getting it
then for sure
it's on the boys dude that's what it is
it's on you because you're the you would
you would have been the most resistant
in my mind yeah you're the most
squirrely what about [__] Colleen
I've never honestly you would have been
dodging the needle you're gonna deflect
it I don't think I'm gonna like the
needle I've never had a tattoo it's
gonna suck it's gonna hurt dude and I
just got these hairs in dude it's fast I
just got these mirrors in they'll shave
it too okay get them get them replanted
somewhere dude I guess I guess but we
should go to a place where there's like
multiple
dude we're gonna be there for for ages
waiting yeah we are yeah
well maybe we can make a special
appointment with somebody that I think
we might need to go to a shitty tattoo
shop then because anyone that is like
down to do six people like six shitty
tattoos the Masters aren't gonna do that
they're gonna be like nah I'm good yeah
is this a shitty tattoo
no I feel like we have hi is that one
star review accurate if we tell them the
story dude they'll be like oh that's
[__] hilarious let's agree with this
I bet you there's tattoo artists that
follow us
through the story because free is better
than just shitty free is better than
anything bro I could do that
we they're standards still and then if
somebody asks me oh why'd you do that to
do I'm like because it was free idiot
[__] morons
that's what the tattoo says this was
free are we able to do this in August in
August that's coming up soon we should
do it all together at the same time dude
I got a machine right now do it right
now you have a tattoo machine yeah I
can't do my whole leg that's now why do
you have a tattoo machine why didn't
learn how to shade but I did the [__]
outline is the ink inspired I don't
think it expires yeah if it does it's
expired immediately
[__] office yeah uh I got I got
homies at my tattoo
yeah let's do it wow cool
so Anthony you don't have a problem
getting a tattoo on your in your Lego I
I definitely by myself have a problem
with this tattoo but if all of us get it
there's rules you have to this is if
this is a prank and it ends up with
Anthony's only when it gets it oh my God
we all Bale then that means my other leg
I'm gonna put respect none as well
respect none I fear everyone like that's
all we don't get sick as dragons we all
come out what you get we get our back
blasting what does mine say we get sick
as lions and [__] and he's like oh [__]
man it does suck that we're not getting
a sick-ass Dragon I will say that's the
worst well we got it we gotta make this
a JK Adventure All right we gotta get it
recorded on my [__] I might get another
attack dude is it is it possible I might
get another one is it possible to get
them at I mean we don't have to I'll be
simultaneously getting it I think we at
most get a three at a time that's true
how long do you think this is we could
just make it a day thing and we just all
hang out yeah [__] it let's do it
how long did that take that one 45
minutes so it's fast uh that's a little
long time
I feel like we do it we go to Buffalo
mofo and we [__] hang out and we
don't take shits
also at the same time yeah we don't
flush and this has to be the first one
to get it because I gotta be the first
you're the squirreliest nah bro I'm not
the first one yeah you go first so we
can watch him oh dude you're gonna be
the first one no no you because it's
your first Nick and Steve at the
oh my God all right Steve you needed
everyone knows I'm doing it yeah we're
doing it and everybody
I don't care nobody has doubts about me
getting a tattoo
yo I haven't done anything you haven't
had any work done since [__]
2008 or something hey does the tattoo
hurt
like barely on the shin well nowadays
don't they have like different
anesthesias yeah I want the rubs I want
all of them for your first one oh so all
of a sudden I can't get a rub I gotta
get a tattoo against my will
can I go under please sometimes your
artists won't do it really yeah some of
them are there because they like the ink
doesn't set as good as or whatever we'll
make Nick do the traditional [__]
time oh my god dude I'm definitely
taking a shot first no [__] way I'm
not they're gonna advise against it but
at the same time it's not a giant piece
where yeah it doesn't matter yeah if
you're doing like a six hour back tab
then be like yeah don't drink I just
want my whole butt [__] to be covered up
trying to get this whole thing blasted
all right guys all right we're gonna
we're gonna talk about the this
logistically off camera we're gonna set
it up okay you know not obvious bro if
if after we get it the Bots get cleared
and we're like 1.8
and then when we hit two million we get
dragons oh yeah
who made the two million rule up I
thought we were just getting them if we
survive another I honestly blame Ryan
for perpetuating it on social media
either way it's this is the year August
yeah we hit it we hit a whole year since
we said we might not survive yeah it got
it got merged into one but it it is
still do you guys even have a quest
tattoo no oh [__] no we're not that
stupid
what do you think they're gonna think
about this one [__] hilarious this is
the it's the sense of humor behind it
it's so like I wouldn't do it if it
wasn't based on a joke exactly if it was
just some random [__] yeah I'm more
inclined to do it based on a joke than
based on an actual meaningful thing same
that's true that's true I mean that is
meaning though like the meaning behind
this tattoo there's it's just such a
[__] good story huge dramatic music
right here and the bro honestly the
Brotherhood of this place yeah is what
is the meaning behind it for me that's a
year in the making but the joke of it
makes it even funnier yeah so it's it's
perfect for me it's a perfect storm it's
also the fact that when we said it we
didn't really think we would have to do
it yeah I didn't think so either that's
what makes it even better you know it
would be also good not letting Colleen
off the hook we gotta get clean somehow
just to get her butthole tattoo yeah
yeah yeah
she said the butthole thing I didn't
even know why she was coming up with it
but we just force every guest ever as
well his realtor has to get it yeah
they're like hey uh you know you guys
were a part of JK now you gotta you
gotta do what's the mortgage has to get
it
Holly George
talking about that do you if I were to
get like my my pugs tatted on me would
you guys do it too get your pugs tatted
on you oh is that the butt tattoo you
want just offer for everybody just since
we're all doing a tattoo next tattoo I'm
getting is woo but it has to hit like 10
bucks that's what me and cryptocorner
have a bet if it hits 10 bucks where are
you getting the woot at I don't know
we'll figure it out right here so when
you take your hat off right after
where is it at right now huh where's Wu
at right now it's like 20 cents let's go
on 10 bucks baby if it goes to 10 bucks
it'd be [__] wild yeah wild that's
why I'd have to do it I would go to
Every tattoo parlor and yell at people
for not giving me a tattoo until I got
the test you gotta get old English on
your chest
ooh Gothic sand I like this logo though
I like the logo oh yeah yeah windings
yeah wing dings so yeah this could be
the start of me getting like real tatted
like really really tatted dude Steve's
gonna look like [__] MGK by the end
of the year once he gets his first one
he's gonna be like yo I got an inch
it's me Nikki's like lipstick outline on
his neck I'm so hyped that Nick's down
to get it though nah dude I'm not
[__] that changes everything for me
because now I know we're in yup I knew
we were gonna bully Nick into it anyway
because we bullied people in and off of
this show that's what we do I do feel
pretty bullied right now
I do feel free right when I get that ink
and we're all [__] really really
blinded that's when I'll rip up that
letter of resignation
you gotta do it the same time though
yeah
dude that's so tight man I'm glad you're
gonna do it I don't know your body's so
nice and clean I can't wait on it
finally
I can't believe a bunch of Asians are
gonna get wrong Asian characters
next shark's gonna happen it might mean
more to Joe though because actually
Japanese
and I know that it's wrong because my
mom was the one that called it out I
can't read it and then your mom's gonna
say wait that's the one you know
you know dude please go
yeah [__] kill your monster I should
I should imagine this guy walked around
Hawaii where some Japanese people gonna
be able to there's a lot of jobs
I hope Tycho wait I like grows up one
day and he's just like inspired by it
and gets the same tat he knows his dad's
[__]
is that a quote Daddy I know you're
returning that's what he gets my dad's
[__]
is that what you tell his teacher I
think best of all for five years
straight there's been people saying like
JK news is dying
but like we just keep surviving and
growing and I don't know how we're
cockroaches too bad they didn't bet on
it dude because I would love to take
their money
foreign